[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
pastor Doug Batchelor hello friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
gregor McGregor there's a name he was a
Scottish soldier of fortune who fought
alternately for the spanish portuguese
and british in latin american florida
possessing unusual charisma eloquence
and the gift of persuasion he was
progressively promoted to the rank of
colonel
then Brigadier General and he fought in
a number of battles and skirmishes
between 1812 and 1820 when he eventually
returned to Europe McGregor launched a
bold money-making scheme by announcing
that while fighting in the tropics he
had made been made the chief of a small
beautiful and absolutely fictional
country that he referred to as pricey
he claimed the nation was a modern
paradise friendly to Europeans and to
back up his story he even produced
hand-drawn maps and a copy of their
constitution soon the charming and
flamboyant McGregor was the toast of
London lavish parties were frequently
held in his honor as he managed to
ingratiate himself to the many Nobles
McGregor then shifted his Conn into high
gear when he started selling plots of
land in paisa to unsuspecting investors
to raise money for a colony of settlers
when the dust had cleared McGregor had
made off with thousands of dollars
hundreds had invested their savings in
this phony government bonds and land
certificates sadly about 250 emigrated
to McGregor's invented country in 1822
and 23 to find out only a fierce
untouched jungle more than half of them
died in the end mcgregor fled to
venezuela where he was welcomed back as
a hero he died in Caracas in 1845 at the
age of 58 and he was buried with full
military honors in the Caracas Cathedral
McGregor's pious scheme has been called
one of the most brazen frauds in history
did you know the Bible talks about
another slick con artist who offers
people a paradise he doesn't own stay
with his friends we're going to learn
more on this edition of Bible answers
live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
Bible questions welcome listening
friends if you have a Bible question
that's why we have this program make up
your phone and give us a call we have
lines open these are very interesting
times people have a lot of questions
about the Bible and prophecy in
particular we will do our best with the
Bible resources at our fingertips to
answer your questions here's the phone
number again 800 4 6 3 7 2 9 7 that's
800 God says you could also watch the
program streaming on the amazing facts
Facebook page you just type an amazing
facts face book it'll take you there or
the Doug Batchelor face book page and
you can take a little peek at what's
happening here in our Studios in
Northern California one more time the
phone number for your Bible questions
tonight call now
good chance you'll get your question on
tonight's program eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven and I am Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross good
evening friends and pass the bag as we
always do let's stop with the word of
Prayer dear father we thank you that we
have this opportunity to be able to open
up your word and study and we do ask
Lord that your spirit would be with us
we know the Bible is your book and in
order for us to understand it aright we
need the spirit to guide us so be with
us here in studio and be with those who
are listening across the country and
even around the world thank you Lord for
you many blessings in Jesus name Amen
amen
ambassador you opened the program by
talking about this bold hoax to try and
deceive as many people as possible about
a country that first of all didn't even
exist and secondly he didn't have any
ownership of any land down in the
Caribbean or South America and yet he
was able to deceive a lot of people out
of a lot of money and then you mentioned
just before he went on the air not only
did he do this in England but eventually
he tried the same stunt in France before
going back to South America yeah it you
know when you think about it was really
mean because some people believe that
they gave up their life savings they
took two ships across the ocean to the
coordinates he had given for this
country which of course they ran into
the Mosquito Coast there's nothing there
and I guess many died from hunger and
malaria and
and um it makes me think a little bit
about another con artist that was
offering a kingdom he didn't even own
you can read about it in the Bible in
Luke 4 verse 5 during the great
temptations of Christ it says then the
devil taking him Jesus up onto a high
mountain he showed him all the kingdoms
of the world in a moment of time and the
devil said to him all this authority I
will give you and their glory for it has
been delivered to me he claimed
ownership of the world and I'll give it
to whoever I wish therefore if you will
worship Me all will be yours here's the
devil say you know I'm I own the world
I'll give it to you and jesus answered
get behind me Satan for it is written
you shall worship the Lord your God and
him only shall you serve now it is true
the devil has you know he kind of
hijacked the planet for a while but
Christ bought it back with his with his
death for each of us and of course a
person needs to make that decision to
personally accept Jesus but if you'd
like to know more about how to win that
same victory that Jesus won when the
chief con artist tried to bamboozle him
we have a book that talks about
something we deal with every day the
book that we have that's how free offer
today is entitled tips for resisting
temptation and as pastor Doug mentioned
this is something that every Christian
faces where the devil is constantly
trying to hoax us or you know deceive us
and so we want to know how can we resist
his temptations we'll be happy to send
this book to anyone who calls and asks
the number to call for that book is our
resource phone line the number is 883
five six seven four seven and you can
answer the book called tips for
resisting temptation again that number
is 885 six seven four seven if you have
a Bible question our phone lines to the
studio here is 800 four six three seven
two nine seven we'd also like to greet
our friends or joining us on Facebook
now we have folks joining us on the path
to death bachelor or dead bachelor
Facebook page as well as the amazing
facts Facebook page and you can send us
your question
matter of fact you can call the number
on the screen there and you can get your
questions on the air can I go to the
phone lines we have Joel listening in
New York Joel welcome to the program how
you doing mr. latrek tabat how are you
doing my question Hank good good good
my question is about Daniel is that
honest and a little confused about when
in the revelation he had in the dream
this is about that he saw a Son of Man
I just want to confirm he serially saw
Jesus we talked before he came to the
world or he saw God in a dream or what
what is that he saw an angel I saw in
you well you guys wanted to confer yeah
when you look in in Daniel chapter 7 in
this vision it says in verse 13 I was
watching in the night visions and behold
one like the Son of man coming with the
clouds of heaven now that sounds of
course like Jesus said he's going to
come in the clouds and he came to the
Ancient of Days that would be God the
Father Jesus is God the Son in
Revelation there you have Jesus
appearing in the first chapter but you
also have angels so it depends on what
verse you're talking about you know
we've to kind of connect the son of man
phrase that you're finding Daniel you
also find it also in Revelation chapter
14 and verse 14 makes it very clear who
that represents verse 14 says then I
looked and behold a white cloud and on
the cloud set one like unto the Son of
man having on his head a golden crown
and in his hand a sharp sickle and it
goes on to describe the second coming of
Christ so here in Revelation 14 it talks
about the Son of man has mean Christ and
we find the same thing also in Daniel so
hey I hope that helps a little bit Joel
but you're on the right track those
visions of the Son of Man that is Jesus
thank you so much for your question
we've got Marcus listening from
Knoxville Tennessee Marcus welcome the
program hi
I want what the image to the beast means
the image of the beast well yeah of
course this is found in Revelation 13
and in Revelation 13 you have two beasts
you've got this great beast that
receives a deadly wound and then it says
I saw it verse 11 it says I saw another
beast rising up out of
the earth first beast rises up out of
the sea second beast rises up out of the
earth and he tells the world to worship
the first beast whose deadly wound is
healed and now an image of course is a
likeness
it means effects simile a representation
the idolatry of course is forbidden in
the Bible when you read in Revelation 13
to understand it you almost need to be
aware in Daniel chapter 3 Nebuchadnezzar
king of Babylon tells everybody to
worship the image he's made if they
don't worship they'll be killed in the
last days there's going to be a
confederacy of two great religious
powers that are going to be a pasta
sizing and many believe that one is
going to be based in Europe in Rome and
the other one based in North America now
I'm a loyal American but I this is what
prophecy says that a lot of Catholics
and Protestants are going to drift away
from the Scriptures they're gonna make a
political ID with boy I tell you we're
on the verge of something now - they're
gonna make a political religious
organization that is going to compel
people to worship based on based on the
way that two people were forced to
worship during the dark ages this beast
received a deadly wound but it's healed
well it's more than we can answer in
three minutes I wonder if we can send
you a lesson on that Marcus we've got
well let me see who is the Antichrist -
the mark of the beast well we've got -
matter of fact and you can ask for both
we'll be happy to send it to you the one
is called the mark of the beast talking
about the first piece to Revelation
chapter 13 then we have a study guide
called the USA in Bible prophecy that I
think we'll get more into what the image
of the beast is and we'll be happy to
send this to you all you need to do is
give us a call the number is 883 five
six seven four seven and ask for the
study guy called the mark of the beast
as well as the study guide called the
u.s. in Bible prophecy their closest if
Marcus or anyone would like to learn
more call the number we'll have to send
it to you thank you for your call we've
got Allen listening in Indiana Allen
welcome to the program oh what an honor
it is to be on the program
um I just want to say thank you for you
guys administrating it changed my life I
was a high ranking drug yeah gang member
that was involved in a lot of horrible
things and I got seven felonies tak my
face in sixty years master Lord to send
me in the right direction I got ahold of
amazing facts the richest caveman and it
changed my life
Oh what's your him well thanks so much I
want for that testimony but now let's
get your question because you're gonna
make me cry otherwise eighteen years
drugs and alcohol free thanks to you sir
oh well appraisal it's thanks for ward I
appreciate it so much
okay so my question is is when I first
started studying the Bible I started
thinking that that the Angels was
created prior to the six-day creation
week and then I started here in the last
year I've been really studying Genesis
because my kids go to school and they're
getting caught evolution and all this
stuff and I really wanted to enforce
them on the Genesis story and so I
started studying Genesis and I can come
to the conclusion that the angels were
boy and you might have done it one of
the your programs because I also
listened all Joel Cruise's stuff as well
I'm wondering was the angels and Satan
which was obviously an angel um was he
made in the six-day creation week and if
so if you allow a follow-up angel is and
Adam and Eve had their first kid when
there's 120 years old ish somewhere in
that area alright let have a fall within
the first hundred years well let's talk
about that great question you know from
what we see in the Bible Adam and Eve
were created now when it says in the
beginning God created the heaven and the
earth it doesn't mean he made the angels
that week it's an over sweeping headline
that back in the beginning everything
was made by God but before God made man
the angels existed because they are the
ministering spirits of God and I think
in the book of Job Pastor Ross and I
can't remember the verse it says when
creation happened the angels of God the
sons of God shouted for joy
they had to exist before creation and so
I frankly think that God not only has
life here on earth
I believe there are other unfallen
worlds that the Lord has made in you
know if the cosmos is infinite and that
way back you know we can't even pin a
time on it that millions of billions of
years ago when God made his angels
probably one of the first angels he made
was Lucifer and you found that verse
yeah
that's job chapter 38 it's talking about
creation it talks about when the morning
stars sang together and all the sons of
God shouted for joy
so it's referring to a time the verse
just before that says to what were the
foundations fastened or who laid the
cornerstone or talking about the
creation of the earth and here it says
when that happened the sons of God
shouted for joy it says the morning
stars sang together we know stars in
Bible symbol refers to angels according
to Revelation chapter 1 yeah and
Revelation 12 it says Satan he's cast to
earth a third of the Angels follow a
third of the stars follow there later
same chapter thinking calls main JAL's
so yeah Alan died if thank you so much
for your testimony that's so encouraging
and but I I do think the angels were
existed before the world was created you
would really enjoy our cosmic conflict
DVD I don't know if you've ever seen
that but if you go online Alan and you
just type in cosmic conflict Doug
Batchelor you'll see you can watch it
for free I think there's a
high-resolution version we've uploaded
so people can just watch it for free
alright thank you for your : ik school
of the behaved he is let's see we've got
Kris calling from Sonoma California
Kris welcome to the program thank you
it's been a long time god bless you guys
well god bless you thank for calling
back I'm glad to be back never left amen
I the pastor Doug I was I I think I kind
of know the answer to this question I
just want to hear some good news
proclaimed can you please elaborate on
what the latter rain means in prophecy
yes and I quoted pastor Ross even this
week from that in Zechariah forget the
verse
we should ask of the Lord rain and the
time of the latter rain Hills and
flashing clouds that's a symbol for the
Holy Spirit it just so folks understand
the in the Hebrew farming economy they
didn't have all the artificial
irrigation we have they knew there was a
season when typically they'd get their
rains and and they used a lunar calendar
and sometimes the rains are affected in
the tides by the moon so they would
plant their seed and then they would get
this first rain that would then sprout
the seed and there'd be periodic rains
through the year and then there was a
final rain just before harvest that
would ripen the grain and you didn't
want it to rain right during the harvest
because that could wreck the the ripened
grain but there was a final rain they
called the latter rain and many believe
that when Jesus poured out his spirit at
Pentecost that was the former rain
Christ had been sowing the seed of the
gospel his word the church exploded
there was great growth that sprouted up
through history it's been maturing
before he comes as pictured in
Revelation he's coming to harvest the
earth there's another outpouring of the
Spirit that will happen that will bring
revival to the church great proclamation
of the gospel great harvest of believers
then Jesus comes and there'll be great
persecution just before the end as well
now the verse referring to is a Cariah
chapter 10 verse 1 it says ask the Lord
for rain in the time of the latter rain
the Lord will make flashing clouds and
He will give them showers of rain grass
in the field for everyone
perfect so thank you know we do have a
book that talks about the Holy Spirit
our greatest need and we'll be happy to
send you a free copy if you'd like to
receive it call and ask the number is
883 five six seven four seven and again
just after the book called
the Holy Spirit the need and we'll send
that out to anyone who calls and asks
we've got Dalma listening in Texas del
Mar welcome to the program hello hello
hi thank you for calling yes I have a
question about Genesis chapter 26 verse
5 and it's talking about Abraham and how
he kept gods charging his commandments
his statues and his laws yes woman
what's the difference between the
all right very good question first the
easy one is the 10 commandments are a
distinct moral law sometimes it's called
the Decalogue deca means 10 like a
decade the 10 words are the 10
commandments and you can read where God
says in Deuteronomy chapter 4 he says
and I gave them my law even Ten
Commandments and my servant Moses at
that time also gave him other statutes
and laws so you've got the Ten
Commandments and then beyond that you've
got certain civil laws they had laws
about ceremonial laws about the priests
and sacrifices there were health laws
now when you look at the my commandments
probably the one that we think about is
the Ten Commandments even though they
weren't written on stone by the time of
Abraham that came later on with Moses
Abraham was very much aware of the Ten
Commandments we know that breaking one
of the Ten Commandments is sin where it
says my statutes that's referring to
probably more so the ceremonial law the
ceremonial was expanded upon in the time
of Moses but even back in Abraham's time
they still had the sacrificial system
and circumcision can circumcision yes so
that's part of the Sarah or the statutes
of the ceremonial law and then my laws
is just in general if you want to clump
all of them together you can put them on
that last or third phrase meaning all of
the commandments given by God whether
they be the Ten Commandments or whether
they be part of the ceremonial law or
even social laws mm-hmm and that verse
again that I was fishing for before was
Deuteronomy 4:13 says so he declared to
you his covenant that he commanded you
to perform even the Ten Commandments he
wrote them onto tables of stone and the
LORD commanded me at that time Moses is
speaking to teach you statutes and
judgments that you might observe them in
the land where you go to possess and so
I and if you take a look you'll see
Delmar we have a free offer we'll be
happy to send you called written stone
and it talks about the laws of God the
number to call to receive that is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and again you can just ask for the
study guide
on the Ten Commandments called written
in stone we got Camille listening from
West Virginia Camille welcome to the
program is it Camilla yeah
Wester she might have her mute on all
right let's try someone else okay we go
to let's see we've got Christina
listening from California Christina
welcome to the program
I have a question and and it is kind of
like it kind of seems everywhere I go
full church and remembers everywhere as
I come in contact with people who speak
and gossip or profanity and I want to be
a good witness and so I feel like
there's something that I should say you
know when I kind of love the way that
you know I kind of don't like that or I
don't agree with that you know I'm glad
you asked that question I'm not sure I
know the best answer because I think the
same thing all the time everywhere you
go and you know sometimes you're
standing on the corner wherever you're
at pop in the air in a store and
there'll be kids you know they're you
know 15 16 years old and they're using
just terrible language and it's not like
they're just doing it off on a corner
you know trying to impress their friends
they're doing it in public with no shame
and I've wondered before Lord do you
want me to say something there you know
their parents aren't around you know
pastor also and I occasionally we play
racquetball with some friends good guys
and every now and they'll use words and
you just cringe and you wonder if you
know someone well enough I think you
know you got to be careful if it's
someone else's kids you might talk to
their folks and say you know you should
really really encourage them not to do
that in public or say Michael are you if
you say that but and if you have a
friend you know I've got some friends
that are not believers and I hear them
use the name of the Lord and I might say
you know I'm a Christian and boy it just
makes me cringe could you just do me a
favor not to do that around me they
usually apologize oh yeah I forgot sorry
so you just I think in every case you
got to pray for the Holy Spirit and how
you do it you want to be real gentle but
yeah I think sometimes people need to be
called on the carpet there's there's no
reason to talk dirty in public like that
now
and talk dirty that time anyway anytime
that makes sense yeah thank you so much
Patti yeah I just pray for the Holy
Spirit to guide you in each case might
be a little different we got time for
another call before the break we got
that Andrews listening from Long Island
New York
Andrews welcome to the program hello hi
how are you guys good how are you doing
thank you for your ministry yeah I'm
doing good too
and your question oh yeah my question is
um what in the Bible you find this more
time of trouble that's some song
denominations mention it yeah it does it
famous big trouble alright thanks so
much great question every now and then
you'll hear somebody ask a question
about a small time of trouble and they
do that in relationship to the
tribulation that's because many
Christians believe I think it's pretty
clear in the Bible that the great Great
Tribulation when the seven last plagues
are poured out that's a time when the
saved are saved and a lost are lost as
it mentions in revelation 22 there's no
changing times an example of this would
be in Noah's day when Noah and his
family got on the ark you know he made
his final appeal and God shut the door
well when God shut the door the loss
were shut out Noah and his family were
shut in they were saved the wicked were
lost but life went on for seven more
days probation had closed up until the
time probation closes there is going to
be some persecution in the world where
Christians are going to be brought
before kings and rulers we're going to
be preaching there'll be some hard times
can't buy or sell and there'll be a time
of testing this is gonna be the small
time of trouble we don't know how long
it is some say well will it be a year
three and a half years and doesn't I
don't think specifically say the time of
Jacob's trouble I think happens right
after the plagues fall and that's a time
when the devil is gonna just try to
overwhelm God's people with
discouragement that they can't be saved
make him lose faith even though his
destiny is sealed
still come down with great wrath and
they're gonna they're gonna be just
wanting to know that their sins are
forgiven just like Jacob when he
wrestled with the Lord because he had
betrayed his father and his brother and
Esau was on his way to enact revenge and
he just wrestled in prayer with God
there'll be a time like that I think
just a couple of verses when I passed a
deck you got Matthew 24 talking about
this what we call the small time with
trouble or the little time of trouble it
says that they will deliver you up to
tribulation to kill you and you'll be
hated by all nations for my name's sake
and then it says and many will be
offended will betray one another will
heat one another and then many false
prophets will arise that takes place
before probation closes and then you
find in Daniel chapter 12 verse 1 it
says Michael stands up and there will be
a time of trouble worse than the world
has ever seen
that's the great time of trouble when
the seven last plagues are pulled out
but at that time God's people are
protected right they might their faith
might be tried but they'll be protected
from those plates that come so hey I
appreciate that I hope I hope that makes
sense and yeah there's probably we're
going through a little time of trouble
right now in North America and the world
very interesting almost apocalyptic
headlines you know friends we're gonna
come up on a break here in just a minute
and a half and so you stand by we see
Tim Logan Emanuel and Akash we we see
you waiting and there are some lines
open if you'd like to call in with your
Bible question don't go away this is
really a good time for people to draw
closer to the Lord you know people are
many are sequestered in their homes and
their kind of self isolating well you
know no I had to store food on the ark
to get ready for the flood there's a
storm ahead now is a good time to be
feeding on the Word of God and if you
are parents you get kids home turn them
to the word they're maybe a little
anxious about what's happening tell them
they can cast their cares on Jesus that
he loves them and they don't have to
worry but good time for us to draw
together with our families and with the
Lord and even as a as a people you know
there's all
we just did some special messages this
weekend at amazing facts and if you go
to the Mason facts Facebook page you can
go to the Doug Batchelor Facebook page
we posted some special messages that the
one was used as a worship service this
weekend and think you'll find some
encouragement in that now don't go away
we're just gonna take a break we're
gonna get right into your questions when
we come back
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers see his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by Pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273 and good evening to
pastor pastor as well thank you yes yeah
question my question is ask questions
should we participate in the 2020 census
I just wanted your insight on it as a
bachelor like what do you think should
we well yeah that's that's a good
question
there is nothing wrong now David got in
trouble when he numbered Israel but it
wasn't because there was anything
morally wrong with you know doing a
census David did it through the military
and they had been instructed to do it
through the priests and when the priests
were to take a census Moses said that
each person was to pay a little temple
tax and David just kind of did his own
thing and he knew better and he was
doing it out of pride there's no moral
dilemma that I know of Akash if if
someone comes to your door and this is
look we're just working for the
government so we can figure out you know
how to manage everything from the
military to taxes and stuff who's in our
country there's you know big questions
about immigration and how quick
immigration is is growing and I don't
see there's any moral problem they
usually just ask you you know some basic
if there's any question you're
uncomfortable with I think you can tell
them that's personal
want to answer and so yeah I participate
as long as they're not asking questions
you think you have to compromise any
moral prerogative yeah yeah we finding
the New Testament the Bible tells us as
far as possible we want to cooperate
with the civil authorities that includes
not only paying taxes but if you called
to provide some service for the good of
the country you want to do that and I
think if they do a census as far as
possible if it's not contradicting a law
of God you want to be supportive I had a
heart attack about 20 years ago most
people don't know I shot a bear that
came to my house he was trying to get in
my house the next day a forester shows
up on my front door you've been to my
house out in the middle of nowhere I
thought how did he know that I had to
kill that bear last night and he said
I'm here to take your census what I saw
that Forester there I thought oh man I
had no choice and I was ready to confess
to the bear
don't worry friends it's out its out
enough people know about the bear so
it's not a secret anyway he said the
other hiring everybody to take the
census and we don't have much to do this
time of year so we're up you probably
thought the bear had some tracking
device I was a special bear I thought
how did he know anyway sorry
that's a diversion friends all right
thanks to a collocation we've got Darryl
listening from Florida Darryl welcome to
the program a pastor John Ross and
pastor Doug you know how they had the
Pope on TV here recently praying at st.
Peter's Square and I thought you know
I'd be interesting if you know like the
next day or two that you know the
coronavirus
for instance goes away and then you know
would that be the you know that'd be
quite a miracle it was a revelation yeah
yeah that would be that would heal the
the fully heal the deadly wound I tell
you know you're not the only one who's
asked me that question and people have
wondered you know the Bible tells us in
prophecy that
in Christ said they'll be false christs
and probably the devil is reserving his
masterpiece of masquerading as the
savior for just before the end times and
many people have thought well boy what
the world really is ripe now for someone
to impersonate Christ no I don't know
that's going to happen right away and
yeah when the I saw that eerie picture
on the news of the Pope out there by
himself not from his balcony but right
in the middle st. Peter's Square where
they've got the big gathering area doing
a solo Mass and nobody around and it's
kind of a haunting picture but yeah I
fell suddenly the plague came to a
standstill in Italy that would give him
a lot of credibility so I I think I see
what you're talking about Darrell very
interesting and we do you know we need
all the prayers we can get right now for
this but this virus a lot of people are
really struggling and of course there's
the medical challenges there's a health
issue and then there's the financial the
wealth issue in that this is probably
going beyond recession and it may cause
a a global depression at this point a
lot of people are anxious so there's a
fear component that goes with it and
that's why it's so important for a
Christian to remember we've got a peace
that passes understanding jesus said
don't be afraid in the world you'll have
tribulation but I have overcome the
world
Curtis is next listening in Tennessee
Curtis welcome to the program yes good
evening how you doing mr. Johnny mr.
good doing great thank you for calling
it's great thank you for answering my
call just had a simple question that was
kind of pleasant in my mind do either
you guys think that the continent of
Antarctica was formed after the first
flood in the first earth day you know
well and now I'm kind of getting out of
my wheelhouse of expertise my you know
I'm not a geologist my opinion is from
reading Christian geologists is that
there probably was one continent before
the flood and that the flood caused you
know just very radical tectonic shifting
happening at that time Antarctica was
separate
from you know the other mainland I don't
know that they just you know from
geology they see similarities in the
coasts between head Arctic and parts of
African and Malaysian but I'm kind of
guessing there Curtis so I think it
happened during the flood and I think
the pyramids were built I think your
second party question you're asking
about the pyramids
I think the pyramids were built
following the flood I know they're
extremely sophisticated did you've been
to the pyramid
no I have oh you've been Israel yeah
I've been to Egypt and I went inside the
Great Pyramid and I'll tell you what boy
they don't let you inside anymore but I
went back you know thirty years ago when
you could go up in it and you could see
the the laser tight lines between these
extremely complicated cut massive stones
you think I don't think there's any
company in the world today that has the
technology to cut stones that precisely
and fit them together huge stones can't
put a knife between there seems no no
mortar and so the technology they had I
think they brought some of it over from
the other side of the flood there just
was a wisdom they had back then that we
don't understand good question
appreciate that Curtis thanks so much
for calling Trudy is listening from
Virginia Trudy welcome to the program
yes yeah and I want you to tell me the
name of the town you're calling from
Tappahannock no Indian word I figured
that wher well thank you so much now get
real close to your phone because you're
kind of breaking up what's your
questions okay can you hear me yeah okay
I don't know when I hear commentary
biblical commentaries and religious
people in general inferred that
Bathsheba tempted
gave it to sin I understand he sent for
her she had no choice unless she wanted
to be in place of Nebuchadnezzar and you
know ruddy Hebrew boy she had to come to
that so why is it that they say that she
was complicit in the Senate well that
that is a good question and you know
some of it we can only speculate I can
tell you what the Bible says and then I
can sometimes tell you what the Bible
doesn't say she was bathing in a
courtyard David saw her from his roof
the argument of some commentators is she
knew where the palace was and she knew
that David was home and that she was
trying to lure him it doesn't say that
in the Bible that is what you call
speculation it entirely possible that it
was just her bath time and she you know
didn't know anyone was gonna look over
the walls and but when David did send
for her it doesn't say David raped her
that I think would have been included in
the text which means that you know he I
think you know he used his position in
his power and keep in mind David was a
handsome man
David was a musician a poet and her
husband was away and he took advantage
of her vulnerability but yes she I think
still had a choice in the matter I don't
think he raped her so somewhere in the
middle you get the truth there yeah just
to add to that a little bit when she was
when she did discover that she was
pregnant she sent word to David and said
you know I'm with child and it seemed as
though the reason she said that to David
and not to her husband kind of gives the
idea that maybe she was more agreement
with what was happening and then of
course when David came up with the idea
for Uriah to come back home she didn't
tell him either so it is you would
assume that she was in agreement which
may have been a reluctant accomplice but
she was an accomplice yeah so that's a
good question a lot of people have
wondered thank you Trudy and I hope that
helps a little bit and we could be wrong
again there's some speculation that has
to happen there who's next
we've got King bee
listening and candy welcome to the
program hi pastor doc hi Pastor John
thank you again for taking my call I
truly appreciate it I must say I've been
listening to the program ever since I
was in the station line of Camp Lejeune
Marine Corps Base Oh wonderful and on
your program you guys changed my life
amazing which I thank you enough for
that like you really wouldn't understand
the tremendous in fact you guys I've had
in my life so again I truly appreciate
it from the bottom of my heart
oh that's very encouragement Thank You
kandi absolutely so my Kirsten is a
Dillon would be the substitute of prayer
a lot of time again giving this specific
time that we're living in right now I
sometimes when I am praying and I felt
like my mind is sometimes wandering
around and I remember you are preaching
a couple of you know which the Gloria
saying it's a lot of time when you're
preaching you know sometimes your mind
is under you wandering off around to
something else is probably the Holy
Spirit is revealing you something that
you need to pray about but can you can
you kind of like a little bit because
sometimes I feel like I really am
praying like I have to urgent see in the
sincerity the desire to be sincere with
God in my prayer and Isaiah I'm praying
I find myself sometimes wandering around
and I bring myself back now my god
please guide me back please guide me
back so can you kind of help me out it
that's a great question
yeah and but you know just be insured
sure that you're not alone I think
everybody out there our minds when you
think about how many thoughts go through
your mind in a in a you know 10 second
period probably hundreds of thoughts
your your eyes are taking things in all
your senses are taking things in so you
know prayer is like carrying on a
conversation with somebody where you
have to focus on what you're saying the
part of prayer is not just speaking
sometimes you can just be silent on your
knees and listen you know sometimes the
Holy Spirit will make impress you it is
true the devil will sometimes come while
you're praying and he'll put thoughts in
your mind I'm thinking old heaven
forgive me look at what's going through
my mind while I'm trained i but
sometimes the Holy Spirit will you know
and sometimes the devil tries to
distract you from your prayers and
sometimes the Holy Spirit while I'm
praying
Allison I remember someone I need to
call that day or something I need to do
and I had totally forgotten about
so it's it takes practice but I think
you're doing the right thing you bring
your mind back and we have a book where
I talk about this in it's called teach
us to pray and it talks about when your
mind wanders is among other things
that's right we will be happy to send
this to you King bee or anyone wanting
to learn more about how do we pray
effectively the book is called teach us
to pray and if you'd like to receive it
the number to call for that book is a
resource phone line 883 five six seven
four seven you can ask for the book
teach us to pray if you're outside of
north america you can go to the website
just amazing facts dough are g and you
can read it for free online at our
resource library on the amazing facts
web site again thank you for your call
our next caller that we have is dela
listening from the netherlands dela
welcome to the program advisor Ellen
White that it is time for us to leave
the citizen go into that area the
countryside country leaving and how do
you apply to persons who are physically
or financially unable to do so maybe the
housing system in the country where they
are living doesn't really allow them to
do so how do you apply that advice to
such people yeah you know in the Bible
it says and I think is it Isaiah chapter
five where he says woe to those that lay
house the house and field the field so
there's no place where a man might be
alone in the earth and let me see here
and maybe it's Isaiah 7 but I'm looking
through Isaiah here anyway II there are
benefits in living in the country where
and especially in the last days you know
as you get near the end they look at
what's happening in places like Madrid
in Milan in New York City and Wu hen
there's some of these major cities yeah
yep it's Isaiah chapter 5 verse 8 verse
8 I just didn't read far enough you know
God's plan for Adam Eve in the Garden of
Eden was not a metropolis now cities
inherently there's nothing evil about a
city because Jesus is taking us to the
New Jerusalem which is the City of God
where a lot of people will live together
but there's no sin there because
everyone's been redeemed because people
are sinful and our hearts are broken you
get a lot of people in the city at a
concentration of sin it'll be more crime
there'll be more drugs they'll be more
evil influence you're typically going to
have you know more disease and and
problems like that more drugs getting in
a more rural environment you're more
likely to have cleaner air cleaner water
less congestion and a healthier
environment for your family a little
further out you'll have a little more
room to plant trees plant a garden and a
little more freedom and isolation if
there's ever any you know kind of riots
in the city I don't think the message
for Christians is to all run out into
the wilderness and hide yourself from
civilization because the Jesus the Bible
says Jesus went throughout the cities
and villages preaching and so there's a
lot of lost people I think as of about
five years ago the majority of people in
the world are now in urban areas they
used to be in rural agricultural areas
but it's been shifting to the cities
since farming has become more mechanized
so I don't think it's God's plan for
everybody to just pull up their tent and
run to the country it is preferable if
your circumstances do not allow for that
then just say lord help me to be a
witness for you where I am so a person's
got to consider their job their family
their circumstances someone has to be
doing ministry in the cities
best thing is you got a good deal pastor
Ross you kind of live in the country
then you commute down to the city to do
your work and then you head for the
hills after the program yeah so if you
can live on the outskirts of a city
where you can be a witness and still
have the benefits of a little more rural
environment I think there's wisdom in
that but every every person I think
needs to pray for guidance you know I
think in particular when you have a
family and you're looking for the best
influence in in raising your children
you want to think about trying to be on
the outskirts of the city but on the
other hand pastor day there are very
dedicated families that purposely choose
to go to a very populated area to
mission work we have a family that are
committed to to go to India you can't
talk about a more densely populated area
but they're fresh out there right now
they can that's right and we've got
friends that went to Uganda and Kenya
and yeah they get right in the middle of
it win souls yeah you know I wrote and
this is this is plain old shameless
promotion Nikki I wrote a book that just
came out about three months ago and it's
called heading for the hills a
beginner's guide to Country Living
mrs. bachelor and I have had a place up
in the hills pastor Ross has been there
before where we got some land way out
we're off the grid and you know we made
a few mistakes along the way one and I
just want to share what we've learned so
we talked about if you're gonna live in
the country what's some advice
and yet the importance to do ministry in
the city so if you're interested in that
book we can't give that one away it just
came out just go to the amazing facts
website it's called heading for the
hills a beginner's guide to Country
Living
thank you very much Nikki well that was
that was somebody else pastor died we
got Nikki on the phone right now
Massachusetts hi Nikki hi how are you
pastor doug and pastor ross how are you
great thank you for calling this is
actually my first time so it's a
blessing to actually hear from you all
about my question we'll do our best okay
so I had a question in Genesis 2:21 how
it says that God put Adam in a deep
sleep now I know that we're not supposed
to be hooked on details and I was
thinking did God have to actually place
him in a deep sleep to the point that he
was dead and then he brought him back
and the reason why I'm asking that is
because in different Bible verses you
know I know that it's important for us
to look at different Bible verses to
allow the Bible to interpret itself but
I was looking at how Jesus arose Lazarus
from the dead but he also said that he
was asleep also and when he arose the
young girl from you know
death-bed also in brought her back to
life but he also said that she was
sleeping as well so I wanted to ask the
college if he was alive it not actually
hurt well it depends on who your doctor
is and what ya nor under normal
circumstances if you try and take my rib
I'm gonna wake up but I think that when
you consider that God made man the Lord
you know he could enesta size him so he
didn't feel anything and he put him in a
deep sleep
you know the Bible Bible tells us Jonah
was in a deep sleep
when he was in the in the boat fast
asleep he's sleeping through a storm
Jesus was in a deep sleep when he was on
the Sea of Galilee so why don't you have
any thoughts on that yeah you know we do
it all the time now with medicine we can
do surgery and put somebody to sleep and
you know they very much alive through
the process and wouldn't be very hard
for God to cause a deep sleep where he
didn't feel any pain and take out the
ribbon of course the healing process now
if you have surgery you got a long
healing process and a lot of pain
probably welding right oh yeah I don't
think Adam felt any pain I had a big old
scar on his side that had to heal over
time so yeah it was a special surgery
yeah that's right you know I'm so
thankful that if you go back I think 120
years or so they had no anesthesia for
operations and you think about those
wars where they just you know people
were losing limbs and things in the
surgery and they just hold you down and
it's it's such a wonder of medicine now
that they can put a person out for
painful surgery so thank you appreciate
that Nicky
we've got Jude listening in Pennsylvania
Jude welcome to the program sponsored by
how are you very good
and your question usually the first time
first yeah first time caller with a
longtime follower my question is in
regards to 1st Corinthians 15 verse 52
we had this past weekend we cut for
salad we had our Bible studies and this
is one of our assignments hello was the
last Trump it's all about so cuz
wondering how many comforts are there
to begin with and what's the last hump
it's all about me well that is a good
question you know of course there is a
trumpet that blows you've read in 1st
Thessalonians chapter 4 the Bible tells
us that the the dead in Christ will rise
the Lord Himself descends of heaven with
a shout the voice of the Archangel the
trumpet of God and the dead rise when it
says the last trumpet a person might
wander the last of which well you have
seven trumpets in Revelation that kind
of cover the military history of the
church and this last trumpet is the
trumpet of the Lord's coming I used to
watch these cowboy and Indian movies
where I don't know there's probably
politically incorrect but you'd have
people that were in some desert fort and
they're under attack and the flaming
arrows are coming over the fort and then
all of a sudden you'd hear the trumpet
in the distance that would go the
cavalry is coming it was like rescue all
they used to do that in battles where
the trumpets were a signal of a victory
and this is I think that last trumpet
battle where Christ comes absolutely you
know a trumpet was used to announce or
to gather together or to proclaim some
special proclamation and here it is
Christ is coming the battle is over the
dead in Christ are raised so I think
that trumpet there just signifies the
end of the Battle of Earth Jesus comes
to take his people home and there were
awakened the dead those dead in Christ
Thank You Jude hope that helps a little
bit all right we've got Aaron listening
from Oregon Aaron welcome to the program
a good evening gentlemen
I was hoping you could expand upon how
in the New Testament it says we are
saved by faith through grace but how
also in Romans it says we are judged by
our deeds and how in james's says faith
without works is dead ooh good question
before we run out of time
there's a free offer I think you'll
enjoy and it's called does God's grace
blot out his law so just make a note of
that does God's grace blot out his law
one of the big debates that's happened
through history it still goes on today
we are saved by grace through faith
revelation says behold he's coming in
the clouds I forget chapter one to judge
every man according to his works mm-hmm
said verse seven or yes yeah so it says
we're saved by grace but says we're
judged by our works because your works
your actions show it says show me your
faith without your works I will show you
my faith by my works and that's James we
show our faith by our actions and so if
a person is saved by faith they will
there'll be a difference in the works so
like Jesus said don't say Lord Lord many
will say Lord Lord and they do not the
will of my father in heaven so we should
be doing the works if our hearts really
have been changed if we are born again
if we love and trust the Lord you know
it begins with faith trusting in God
receiving his forgiveness but once we
receive he's given at ease forgiveness
how are we to live that should change
the heart that you create a desire to
serving not that our obedience earns our
salvation God gives it to us but now
that we have it how do we live yeah when
when a young man falls in love there's
all kinds of behavioral changes and all
of a sudden he starts cleaning behind
his ears and doing things he's never
done before because he's in love and so
the behavior changes hey I hope that
helps a little bit get that free book
called does God's grace blot out his law
and the number pastor Ross the number to
call is our resource phone line eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven as to the book does God's grace
blot out the law friends we are living
in amazing times and we hope you'll make
the most of amazing facts keep us on the
air nothing more important than
Christian ministry now simply go to our
website amazing facts dot o-r-g
and you can click donate god bless we'll
talk again next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California if you enjoy
hearing solid biblical answers on Bible
answers live you can have those same
insights at your fingertips through the
amazing facts prophecy Study Bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols chart and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope 'dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five three eight
seventy to seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five can't get enough amazing facts
Bible study you don't have to wait until
next week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vo RG DT no amazing backs has
a free Bible school that you can do from
the comfort of your own home it includes
27 beautifully illustrated study lessons
to aid in your study of God's Word sign
up today for this free Bible study
course by calling 184 257,000 that's one
eight four four two one five 7,000
[Music]
for life-changing Christian resources
visit AF bookstore calm
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF as a RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at
[Music]
you